you instagrammed a picture that has to
do with the problem you said that you
have with the best friend and i was
curious in exploring this it has to do
can you explain what this is you
instagram this photo it's just a glass
and you said that this is a problem you
have with your best friend
so my
very best friend from many many years uh
was we were spending the night i went to
go visit her in new york and right
we had a sleepover and she took her
contact lenses out then and put it in a
little like a glass in our bathroom yeah
and with like a little bit of the
whatever fluid and then um i got up in
the middle night and i drank it
and i drank the contact lenses yeah i
took it and put some water and i drank
it and then the next day she was like
where are my
contact lenses and i was like oh they're
like in my they're floating around my
belly so i've done this before i've done
this twice before in our relationship
and wait a minute so you've done this
three times three times
three times you've gotten you've seen it
gla first of all who sees a glass of
water lying around and goes
nobody does that i have a very hearty
constitution i'm like it was supposed to
be there anyway no i don't you're that's
a good point that's a good point i just
feel like if you because we got into you
don't go get a glass and pour water in
it you're just when you see water
anywhere if you just work if you see a
puddle you're just like
[Music]
i feel like if you put your contact
lenses in a glass you need to put like a
little like a tissue over it or leave a
note or something on it so that i know
not to drink i always think i if i had i
don't wear contact lenses but if i had a
glass lying around with water in it i
would think maybe someone's going to put
it in the dishwasher but no one's going
to drink it that's what i would think so
you drink contact lenses
yeah
you've got six contact lenses you've had
in your body that's crazy and i i sort
of was just like just wear glasses i
wouldn't eat your glasses
[Laughter]
very strange very strange behavior i
have to side with your friend on this
one i think i i think don't you i side
with your friend
well i'm just curious if the lenses are
still in there
you're walking around if you've got a
lens crafters in your colon or something
what if she could see through those
what if she was like oh
this is weird what is contact lens fluid
anyway isn't that poison or is it okay
is it no it's just salt water it's
saline oh it's saline yeah yeah do you
notice that it's salt water you're
drinking when you drink that was funny
she asked me the same question and i
guess i was like why is new york water
like
you know that new york water all salty
and lensy
i think it's it's cool that i roll with
things i think so too
there's all kinds of stuff in here and
i'm like i don't care but that's on
purpose yeah
i've got my teeth in there
uh the mindy i'm so happy for you that's
his i always remember this that you were
an intern for us back in new york and
you were 19 years old
that's incredible yeah it was such a it
was such a i don't we always people
bring this up and talk to me about this
but really earnestly it
led me and steered me to this path and i
mentioned that all the time oh that's
very sweet yeah no i mean you know nice
yeah i don't want to make you feel
uncomfortable no not at all as long as i
get a cut uh